one day little Eddie the endorphin went
to play in the park with his receptors
but when he got there he ran into the
obnoxious opioids Hector the heroin
Kurtis the codeine and Fred the fentanyl
the obnoxious opioids punched Eddie in
the face and Eddie tried to fight back
but it was too late
the obnoxious opioids had already taken
Eddie's toy receptors and he was left on
the ground unable to fight back opioids
are substances that inhibit the
transmission of pain information to the
brain by turning on the brain's reward
system endogenous opioids such as
endorphins and ink evelyn's are
naturally produced by our body to help
modulate motivation emotion food intake
in or response to pain like endogenous
opioids opioid drugs stimuli opiate
receptors at the synaptic membrane and
in some places inside the nerve cells
opioid receptors are part of a family of
membrane receptors called g-protein
coupled receptors or GPC ours leggins
binding to gpcrs induces the
phosphorylation of intracellular gdp to
GTP this causes the migration of a
g-protein to a membrane kinase which
Cleaves a phosphate group off GTP
converting it back to gdp and using the
extra phosphate to initiate a cellular
response in opioid receptors the
cellular response results in the opening
of potassium channels in neurons
this causes hyper-polarization which
limit input from nerve fibers that
control responses from pain receptors
once opioids cross the blood-brain
barrier they bind to opioid receptors
that are found throughout the central
and peripheral nervous system this
modulates the activity of the brain stem
which causes slowed breathing that
results in sleepiness and relaxation
addiction and dependence may cause
someone to overdose resulting in
forgetting to breathe and eventually
dying naloxone is a medication used to
reverse an opioid overdose it can be
administered in a nasal spray or via an
injection after 40 minutes after opioid
consumption naloxone separates the
opioid molecules from the receptors and
binds to the receptors itself in the
future improving access to treatment and
recovery services and supporting
research on the role of opioids in pain
and addiction will be key in fighting
the opioid crisis
[Music]